just five against philadelphia good to  see him getting a bucket here  now the other way it is porter for three  yep  he can make that bill and uh he shoots  it like a guard  mike milsap hit four threes in that  victory in denver  uh he's expanded his range uh i think  it's a lot easier for all these guys to  play with jokic  porter drains the triple j early  right over the top of murray and the  nuggets lead 9-4  austin the second round they should have  won that one yeah  mcmillsap got it knocked away got it  back and there's porter  wide open  [Applause]  plumbing to porter can not let him set  and fire  no one emotion for michael and he knocks  that shot down  is seeking to shoot the ball from behind  the line  here's dozier back to porter  porter doesn't hesitate lets it fly  another three in a timeout spurs that's  what i'm talking about junior has tied  his career high in rebounds  and he is hitting from all angles folks  24 for the kid  and the nuggets by six